[MUSIC]
Corporate social responsibility.
I know CSR doesn't seem like
the sexiest of topics but
it's actually a pretty huge idea.
That business even as it
pursues profit maximization,
also has a social responsibility.
And I'm here to tell you that
that social responsibility goes
far beyond kind of shiny PR
donations in your hometown.
But actually we, as the next
generation of Business Leaders,
have social responsibilities that are
going to touch the lives of millions of
people and can even affect some of the
deepest human rights crazies in our world.
Before the GSB, one of the issues I
focused on was Human Trafficking.
Forced labor in the seafood
industry in Thailand.
Migrant workers being threatened,
denied pay and
passports, sometimes even killed
onboard Thai fishing boats.
But then something changed.
Because these fishing boats were buried
deep in the supply chains of the frozen
shrimp we buy at Walmart or Costco.
Then these brands were connected in
the headlines to modern day slavery and
they started paying attention.
I saw this first hand,
sitting around the conference
room table of the biggest
seafood supplier in Bangkok.
Once we had Walmart and
Costco sitting at that table too,
insisting on better labor standards,
we started seeing changes in the industry
that hadn't happen over years of
activists, banging on the doors.
These companies were addressing
huge supply chain and
reputational vulnerabilities.
They knew they had to be part
of the responsible solution.
Instead of being held responsible for
the problem.
That's just one example of this
new business imperative and
opportunity to reimagine
responsible business.
Three numbers will help me make my case.
They'll tell us the scope
of this opportunity,
why we should take advantage of it and
what's next.
First, the scope of this opportunity
of business responsibility is
bigger than you might think.
It can even affect something as seemingly
big and impossible as a distant civil war.
Because 90% is the share of the world's
rubies that once came from Myanmar.
But Myanmar isn't just famous for
its rubies.
It's also famous for
its lingering military dictatorship and
the wars that the military has
been waging against minorities.
Most recently against nearly
1 million Muslims Rohingya.
I was working in Myanmar when news about
these atrocities broke this summer
researching rubies.
I found that that famous military and
those famous rubies are more
linked than you might think.
Because inside every war isn't
just a central difference or
disagreement, but also an economy.
Because that same Burmese military has its
roots sunk deep into Myanmar's economy.
That means they can self
fund their officers and
their wars, be insulated from the effect
of things like international sanctions.
That means that if we trace back the ruby
from some extra special Valentine's gift,
the odds are pretty decent that
the original mining profits
went back to the same Burmese military
that's been waging war on its own people.
Now, [LAUGH] I'm not trying to
just be a Valentine's buzz kill.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Or to say that you not buying a ruby
can single handedly save the Rohingya.
But a company like Tiffany
asking the right questions
might help separate the Burmese
military from its financial lifelines.
Tiffany has avoided
rubies pretty completely
because of their responsible
sourcing commitments.
But this summer, before the Rohingya
crisis, they were exploring it
because they knew if a company as powerful
as Tiffany could insist on sourcing with
fair mining standards, transparency and
no military owned mines,
they might help man mars clean ruby
sector have the change to thrive.
They could be part of the responsible
solution instead of being responsible for
the problem.
Now, [LAUGH] you can still say,
no Mia, I can't afford a ruby ring.
And I work on an online tech product,
no conflict affected supply chains.
So stepping closer to home,
what about Facebook?
Fake news hit Ukraine long before
it became a buzz word here.
Russian government propagandas making
fake Ukrainian Facebook profiles and
using those to drum up local fears and
tensions.
And Ukrainian human rights monitors say
that where this disinformation warfare
was strongest,
actual violence has also been highest.
So can Facebook really get
away with separating its
online platform from the offline
effects it's enabling?
Unilever just pulled their ad dollars
until Facebook can clean up their
fake news problem, because they'd
rather be part of the responsible
solution than be responsible for
the problem.
Next, $6.3 trillion.
This is where we get to start
building the business case for
why good business can be good for
business, why we're going to have to start
caring about things like the human
rights impact of our work.
$6.3 trillion is the value of assets
under management at BlockRock,
the world's largest asset manager.
And their Chairman, Larry Fink,
just wrote a letter to CEOs,
putting them on notice that BlockRock is
going to become a more engaged investor.
One demanding that its company serve not
only their shareholders, but also society.
Vanguard's CEO, with their 4.8 trillion,
is planning to follow suit, and
this is really my kind of competition.
>> [LAUGH]
>> All that means that, like,
this isn't going to be just
about like watered down CSR,
but about integrating this
into core business functions.
So access to investment is one real reason
that a whole variety of human costs
now need to be built into
your business's bottom line.
I'll quickly give you three more.
First, reputation.
It's hard to quantify, [LAUGH] but
we all know it's incredibly important.
A single scandal that links your
brand to a human rights abuse,
no matter how far away, it can be
devastating for sales and reputation.
But on the up side, companies
with values oriented reputations,
tend to suffer a less of a stock hit,
when problems do come up.
Second, there's improved supply chains.
Applying a responsible sourcing lens
means that you can reduce costs,
by building better supplier
relationships or avoiding disruptions.
Third, millennials like us care
about choosing to work for
places that are doing good.
As millennials, nearly half of us in this
room say our loyalty to our employer would
increase if we knew our CEO was
the head of the pack on social issues.
All this means, that if you want to
attract high quality investment, or
earn a resilient reputation, build
responsive supply chains and get the best
talent, you just have to figure out how
to be part of the responsible solution,
not responsible for the problem which
brings me to my last number, one.
One person, that could be you and
not just you see as our team but you as
you face your next business challenge.
Set standards for
your company and its values.
Measure against them.
Commit to digging into hard
problems instead of walking away.
There's no easy playbook for this.
But we now know we have to figure it out.
It's asking who and
where are all the people who's lives
are effected by this business choice?
From website, to farm,
to factory, to mine.
And so the last number is one of hope
because real CSR doesn't
have to be a burden.
It can be the next business opportunity.
It starts with one
responsible person asking one
responsible question, getting on the path
toward being responsible not for
the problem, but for the next solution.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]